notre invité ce soir et claude lanzmann
merci d'être venus monsieur lansman vous
êtes le réalisateur d'un film qui est
projeté actuellement à l' empire vous
êtes échapper si l'on peut dire de cette
projection pour venir nous voir c'est un
film qui dure 9 heures et demi et qui
est une série une suite de témoignages
sur la seconde guerre mondiale et plus
précisément l'extermination du peuple
juif dans les camps de concentration
avec camps d'extermination c'est pas la
même chose pour un du tout pas du tout
c'est ce que j'explique tout au long du
film
les camps de concentration étaient des
camps où les ont été ouverts sur le
territoire allemand à partir de 1933
pour y emprisonner des détenus
politiques des sociaux démocrates des
communistes etc
c'était des camps où les gens étaient
très malheureux et beaucoup ils sont
morts de faim de misère de malnutrition
de mauvais traitements des camps
d'extermination s'était déclenché où les
gens ne restait pas y arriver ils
étaient gazés dans les deux heures il ya
une différence considérable il n'y a pas
eu un seul camp d'extermination sur le
territoire allemand et camp
d'extermination n'ont existé que sur le
territoire de la seule pologne france
roche nous 9 heures et demie de film
c'est une durée tout à fait inhabituel
quel que soit le document il y a déjà eu
des films aussi nos en français vous
connaissez par exemple est d'ailleurs
choix sera présenté dans deux cinémas en
deux séances différentes la 1ère partie
la deuxième partie enfin qu'ils ont pu
voir un jour la première un autre jour
la suite mes choix est un film tout à
fait différent de tout ce qui s'est fait
dans ce genre il s'agit pas d'un
reportage rétrospectif sur les camps
d'internement des exterminations mais
d'une oeuvre de création à travers
laquelle la réflexion s'exerce et et et
dans laquelle les événements se trouve à
la fois raconter et expliquer et
ressenti ses revenus essentiellement
revêt
parce que ça n'est pas une histoire dans
laquelle des gens travaille t derrière
leur bureau raconte des souvenirs
les souvenirs sont faibles j'ai choisi
des protagonistes capable de revivre
cela et pour le revivre il devait payer
le prix le plus haut c'est à dire
souffrir en racontant cette histoire et
claude lanzmann quand vous parlez de
protagonistes vous voulez dire rescapés
de camps d'extermination et aussi ceux
qui ont participé à l'extermination
victime bourreau absolument c'est la
première fois qu'il parle depuis 40
années et qu'on les voit surtout vous
avez eu plus de mal à retrouver les
bourreaux on va retrouver les victimes
j'ai du mal
en tous les cas mais disons j'ai eu plus
de mal à retrouver les bois que les
victimes comment les avez vous persuader
ça si tu sauteras fait et je pense que
la seule façon de comprendre et je n'en
dirai pas plus celle d'aller voir la
fille que signifie le titre et je
pourrais vous répondre je vais vous
répondre deux choses d'abord d'une
certaine façon ça n'a pas d'importance
ce ne sont pas les les noms qui font la
célébrité c'est la célébrité qui fait
les noms célèbres et il faudrait être
très connu mais je répond pourtant à
votre question shoah et le terme
hébraïque pour désigner précisément ce
qui s'est passé et ça veut dire en
hébreu la tempête le désastre la
catastrophe
l'anéantissement la destruction absolue
et ça n'a pourtant pas la connotation
sacrificielle de ou locos holocauste on
offre un bélier en holocauste et on
hébreu cette connotation là n'existe pas
[Musique]